[Music]
joseph is in seattle hi joseph welcome
to the ramsay show
hey dave uh appreciate you taking my
call today sure what's up um
well i'm finishing off the baby steps
and super excited to start building
wealth um i would love to get into real
estate investing but i have no
experience with real estate investing
i'm wondering if it would make more
sense for me at this point rather than
directly reinvesting in real estate to
invest in some high dividend reits that
would be paying like 10 11 dividends uh
or to you know get deeper into actual
physical real estate
either one's fine i mean
the reits in the old days
underperformed growth stock mutual funds
these days there's plenty of reits that
are performing as well
and like you said 10 11 12 percent is
not unusual on a reit especially in a
market where real estate is doing what
it's doing
ree for those of you don't know is real
estate investment trust it's basically a
mutual fund for real estate is how it
functions
and so um
and that way you can put in you know a
few thousand dollars versus uh needing
fifty or a hundred thousand dollars to
be in the real estate world so what do
you make
uh i make about 550 a year
whoa
what do you do for a living
i'm an economist good for you good for
you it's working out for you
i'm proud of you yeah well done great
love oh thank you appreciate it love
what i do
your debt-free house and everything then
you said you finished the baby steps
yeah so well we're just uh actually just
got a pretty good change in my comp
structure this last year and so this
puts us in uh in a range of finishing
the baby steps in the next couple of
years so okay and i think thinking
forward to the next steps gotcha gotcha
okay well when you when you're out of
debt with your home and you make 550 a
year you ought to be able to save up a
couple hundred thousand pretty quick
yeah yeah i mean
it works but again i mean i i don't have
the experience with uh with taking care
of real estate
dealing with the property management
i know there's a lot of understanding of
markets that have to go into finding the
right locations and there's you know a
lot of
a lot of learning to go into there and
as much as i i love learning i also want
to you know get that real estate
investment going
yeah
well i think what you're identifying is
some holes in your knowledge some
knowledge gap
and you fill in that knowledge gap
before you start dropping a couple
hundred grand on something so
probably would start with some reits and
then just go okay i'm gonna go learn
three neighborhoods this year or three
areas of of seattle uh if you're
thinking about residential i'm going to
start talking to and interviewing
property managers learn how this works
i'm going to learn how talk to some
people that have property and start
looking at best practices on landlording
and uh start you know reading some books
on the subject and you know start
filling in your knowledge gap if you
really want to put money in it you need
to know more uh and that will lower the
fear that that we hear in your voice
right now
yeah and when it comes to this you know
obviously we want you to have a paid for
house which you should be able to do
fairly quickly and then i want you to be
paying cash and i know that's going to
move a lot slower than the courses you
hear about out there from real estate
real estate gurus but dave after going
bankrupt you started building back your
real estate portfolio in cash and the
amount of financial peace that gives you
and return that gives you is absolutely
incredible well my rates of return are
ridiculous
i don't have any debt and so the real
estate makes money like crazy when you
buy it that way
um it's a little slower to get started
it's not get rich quick but the guys
that are doing the nothing down real
estate
and that are screaming and yelling about
you know debt is you know people who
tell people cash is horrible don't be in
the cash business they they're screwing
they're having a fit out there flopping
around on the floor foaming at the mouth
and carrying on the guys are doing that
stuff um
basically if you follow that
i defy you to find someone that 10 years
later is not broke
when you do nothing down real estate i
was in a nothing down real estate club
100 of people that were in that club are
no longer in real estate or
they paid it off
and got out of the nothing down world
yeah i'm going to use debt that is my
friend that is my friend that is my
friend dave ramsey and the ramsey people
are crazy well that's because you're
selling a course on nothing down real
estate a get rich quick crap
and it's not going to get rich quick
it's get rich you know you'll get rich i
got rich i had a million dollar net
worth at 25 years old 26 years old made
200 000
but i lost it all because of that
and because i was following
these guys that are running around on
the internet today screaming they're not
on the internet in those days but they
were in hotel ballrooms you know so uh
you know the guy that wrote the book
nothing down robert allen went chapter
11. okay i mean so this just tells you
you know it and not matter robert you
know he just he believed that stuff but
uh but it's just
you know so you you have to decide which
of these paths you're gonna follow and
and i defy you to find a someone that
has followed the get rich quick nothing
down real estate
the um
uh cash is bad
idea that if you know that those guys if
i defy you to find someone that's
followed that strategy and 20 years
later still owns a bunch of real estate
they just don't there's a correlation
between you getting rich slow and then
keeping that wealth and you getting rich
quick and then losing it all exactly
exactly
and if someone has to flop around the
phone with the mouth to get you to do
their stuff
then
run the other way thou doth protest too
loudly
young man you know shakespeare right
there seriously